5:02 p.m. mesolithic tokyo 7:03 p.m. oui t'as
qu'à tout rose is exhausted and lost
everyone is it alone in the weapons 28.5
pleases me either h hollywood we with spices
takes you to moose jaw
so for them it's a wild and
primitive world
it's a cornucopia it was a
former glacier which retreated at the
end of the ice age and which
became a very fertile valley with
very different ecosystems where a
lot of animals meet,
especially large ones  predators and
large herbivores strong the western section
binnington all m night club horse riding and
why not megaphones in evry wascon
pitiful denman definitive of football
the principle is we do not buy our
weapons we manufacture them
at the beginning he will have to really pick up
wood stones started making
his first weapons etc
gradually get more resources
to make weapons
stronger and stronger and solo bar dancing and on the
bard fighting to take your stuff and on
the board gath  ering food one of a
materials everything everything about me at that
time the man was already extremely
advanced already knew how to use the size of
the stone in 150 different ways
so we have a lot of variation in the
type of lens we have a lot of
variation of two  types of arches made with
like at the time of the stones of the
ligaments one of the pieces of bone so that it feeds
even more our desire to make it
fit into the brand far cry
how lady the world is really big
but the world  is really dancing a
lot of activity of
animal systems humans
hunting the day/night cycle will change
what happens so at night the predators
whose prey come out will go to sleep
the player will end up more in there
and  each time we have surprises and 5
in organic
wild eyes in good woman the rocks and
boys are formed
sting because we are great grillage in
which we could die in two to dive into
it it's like this possibility of
changing  s rules we don't have
guns we don't have a vehicle we have to
invent new ways to get
around to fight
we weren't used to
showcasing so much in other parks
exotic ride day beats and style far cry
haddad corse au racing yours come
bigger our son sofiane new un noir
every step could you to i want you
discovery tattoo you want expected